wir sprechen über einen politischen
einem mordversuch in argentinien
anschlag auf vize präsidentin cristina
kirchner dort ein mann hält dir das sind
die entscheidenden szenen eine pistole
direkt vor das gesicht direkt vor die
augen habe die pistole in diesem
dramatischen moment funktioniert
offenbar nicht cristina kirchner lebt
überlebt das ganze spielt sich ab in den
momenten in denen kirchner mitten in
buenos aires
verzeihung in der argentinischen
hauptstadt aus dem auto steigt vor ihrer
wohnung und dann der attentat versucht
die waffe soll geladen gewesen sein mit
vier kugeln der abzug soll gedrückt
worden sein und doch es fiel kein schuss
es waren sekunden die über leben und tod
entschieden der täter der offenbar
morgen wollte ein 34 jähriger
festgenommen mordversuch gegen die
politikerin die unter
korruptionsverdacht steht in argentinien
wo die polizei sowie so tief im
korruptionssumpf steckt cristina
kirchner sie hat diese dramatischen
sekunden überlebt
[Musik]